Our speaker today is Dr. Don Canoe's. He is Fletcher Jones, professor of computer science at Stanford University.
He received the doctorate degree from the California Institute of Technology and remained on the mathematics
faculty of that school before joining Stanford as a professor in the computer science department in 1968.
Professor Kunoth is pursuing a distinguished and quite prolific career in mathematics and computer science.
He is the author of a well-known series of volumes on the art of computer programing,
and he wrote a five volume set of books entitled Computers and Typesetting.
He received the Turing Award from the Association for Computing Machinery in 1974.
He received the National Medal of Science from President Carter in 1979, and earlier this year he received the Franklin medal.
In addition, all these activities, he is an accomplished pianist and organist.
Today, [INAUDIBLE] be discussing some quite significant efforts in computers and typesetting,
which have been carried out under his direction at Stanford over the last eight or 10 years.
The question this morning is can computers help to produce beautiful books?
And I think that we'll hear this presentation and we'll agree with him that they certainly can.
It's a pleasure to introduce to you, Don. Hi.
OK, I'm going to try to learn the technology here. I'm getting my slides to show.
This is a talk that I that I expected I would only give once in my life.
I prepared it for the Stanford Library Associates, the group of people who who help, who helps that for libraries and who also, like me, love books.
And so the question in the title was because a lot of the people in there in that group think
of this as a think think of computers as a threat to the to the ordinary way you think.
How do I get my first slide? OK.
I don't see anything. So there it is.
OK, so the so group of people, I guess it's not it's not exactly the same as the audience here today,
but I think there's enough in common that you'll be that. You bet. You bet. Your share of the ideas.
And although a lot of them I don't think the answer to the question was obviously yes at the beginning.
As Mark said, during the past 10 years,
I've been working on research project with computers and typesetting and Stanford and there and this has resulted in two systems
that are that I'm going to give you an overview of today and and show you some of the things from the archives of the project.
Some of the errors that we made, as well as some of the things that worked well.
Now, the first system is called tax, and it's based on and it's a system for typesetting.
And and the the main interesting thing in retrospect about it is that it has an
underlying structure that seems to be that seems to be quite powerful in building,
building high level applications of type, setting a very simple structure at the basis.
But we found that as we we organized our computer programs around this, we were able to do in about one fifth of the space for the ordinary programs.
We were able to do the things that the other programs were doing in fairly easy and unified way.
So the idea is that we compose a page by building two kinds of lists.
A horizontal list and a vertical list. And each list is made up of other boxes.
And so a box is either a as a single character or or it's a black box, a solid black rectangle.
And we could also use graphics in a box as well.
And then we. But so we have the atomic boxes and then we make molecules out of the boxes by putting them into a horizontal list or a vertical list.
Then the V between the boxes, there is something that unfortunately got the name of blue.
It's more like a spring, really. But this determines spacing between boxes and each.
There doesn't have to be space between boxes and there can be two spaces in a row instead of two instead of box space box.
But the main idea is that these lists contain not only boxes but but also indication of spacing.
And the spacing has three parts to it. One part is that is the normal default spacing.
And then there is a proportionality amounts by which we would like to stretch if we want to,
if we want to back the list to become wider or we can shrink if we want to make the thing tighter.
And if it and the amount of proportionality for stretching isn't necessarily the amount that you would use when you're shrinking.
So there are. So each each aspect of this of the spacing has had its normal amount.
And it's proportionality, stretching proportionality for shrinking.
Now we can't see I can't see too well here, but I guess you can see better than I can from my perspective.
The other the other innovation that went into tech as far as typesetting is concerned is a is that we decided to write to.
Well, we have an idea that that's worked well for breaking the paragraphs into lines of something that actually we first discussed.
We were trying to do through music and art and music professor at Stanford came to me
and and said he wanted to find a good the best way to break pieces into bars and so on.
And so he could typesetting music. And I showed this to my students.
And when we came up with a solution to that, one of the students said, well, you can use this for paragraphs of text as well.
And and what we what we realized is that since the computer is doing the typesetting, it has the whole paragraph in its memory.
It doesn't have to wait and see what's coming up in advance as it is when someone is doing this directly with it,
with an offer where an operator has to is justifying lines and he goes, so.
So a computer has the entire paragraph and and there is a way to then look ahead so
that the problems that are occurring later on in the paragraph can affect the way the.
The first line of the paragraph is broken.
Now, this is one of the slides from an early experiment that we made, and we we have a small number here in the right margin.
This is point seven, eight, all saying that this line is stretched about 78 percent of its capacity for stretching, and this one is 30 percent.
And here's a negative one, which went down 25 percent for shrinking and so on.
For each up amount of stretching and shrinking, we can compute a number that says how bad it is, how how bad that line is.
We get the merits for the for the score for for a line as to how to how much we had to go out of line
and the and the way the tax breaks lines in paragraphs can be understood in this kind of a diagram.
That paragraph that I had before you start at the beginning of the paragraph.
And then there were two reasonable places to to break after the first line, after the word, a year after the word came.
Go back if you can. Look look back at the in olden times when wishing to help one, there lived a king.
We could we could either end it here after the after the that were a or after king or by the word king which would also fit in.
Now at ending after a twenty three hundred fifty seven demerits ending after King has seventeen hundred thirty four demands.
Not after you've broken the first line. Then you have two choices as to where to break the second line.
In that one or after King, there's only one reasonable choice.
Two to break the second line where you've been paying forty six hundred demerits after that one.
And so you can think of this as sort of a roadmap as to.
And the idea is to try to find the shortest, the shortest distance from the beginning of the paragraph down to the end of the paragraph here.
And each of these numbers here says how many demerits you have to pay.
And the shortest path through this maze is going to be the one that that that produces the paragraph that has the best, the fewest total demerits.
So you'll have the best visual appearance. And this is something that computers can easily do.
It's something that people aren't that good at. But it's something the computer could do quite, quite efficiently.
And so we were able to produce automatically better line breaks in paragraphs.
And we did quite a few experiments on how this would improve.
Like we we tried some pages of Time magazine and so on and show that that would come out a lot better if they use if they use this kind of a method.
And it works quite well. So you can also do you do do fun things with it sets set different shapes and so on.
Now, as a first gave this talk, I was also making a plug for Stanford archives, the Stanford University archives.
It has a lot of collection of of know manuscript materials from great writers and so on.
But they also are collecting now a lot of the archives of of of people in Silicon Valley
as it's so that the technological history of this era is we'll be available and so on,
since we did our work in the university. And it's all it's all in the public domain.
We also wanted to to make available the things that we learn while we're doing this project.
And so. So a lot of the materials, not all the junk, but the good stuff,
I think were deposited in the university archives so that people who are going to want to see the
development and what things went on in this project would be able to find the very first book.
The very first thing we ever printed with tech was it was something that we put out as it keeps something for our friends.
At Christmas time, I think it was nineteen seventy eight.
A little a little story about the about my wife's grandmother was written by her and my wife's cousin and and we,
we had a very primitive Xerox graphics printer and the very first attempts at that are computer generated fonts was done in December that year.
And and a man named Homer wethers that with a little offset press in Columbus, Ohio, printed this.
This this first publication that came out, my wife made linoleum block cuts to go with it.
And so this was this was the first time we were typesetting with with the very first prototype of of of tech.
So I don't know, we printed about 60 copies of this.
One of those is in the archives, as you call it, in Kinabalu.
And then I originally worked on tech not really for.
I wasn't thinking of anyone using it except myself and my secretary when I started, I.
I wanted a system by which I could I could write my books on computer science.
And she would help me. But other people seemed to indicate they would be interested in using it, too.
And so finally. And it turned out that the computer was was down a lot that year.
I had nothing else to do but sit down, write a manual for how to use the system.
And that turned out to be a good thing. Whenever you do a system about above about type setting,
I guess the important thing is that it should be able to just use fuel to write a manual for that system in the system itself.
And this means that you have to be able to break the rules. You do you develop a system that that's that's intended for one application.
But then if you if you have it for the application of describing itself,
then all of a sudden you find out that that that there were gaps in your language because he wasn't able to be able to describe yourself.
You have to be able to to say, well,
the thing that normally means the computer takes control doesn't anymore mean the computer takes control so that you
can so that you can show your source files as they are typed instead of as they as they're supposed to be interpreted.
So we came up with a with a preliminary manual in the summer of seventy eight, I think it was.
And this this manual now is pretty rare, I guess, but they've made about 600, 600 copies or something like that.
The American s society got interested in this because they found that their tech was able to do that.
All of the different kinds of printing that that was that were stymieing them at the time instead of just that,
instead of having they had to go to four different suppliers to handle the four different kind of documents that they were doing.
And but that could could do it all with one system also.
Walt Disney came out with a movie about a few years later. Movie, movie, text.
Well, the first system of tech we called Tech 78 the.
But the next one was Tech eighty two. And this is I took this picture mostly because you can see highway eighty two here.
This is El Camino Real in California and it happened to be we had tech in 82,
both in the same slide and now besides tech, there's another system for it.
I'm seeing tech is for typesetting, but there's the other system is called Medford's and this is for the design of typefaces.
And in order to give you some idea as to what metaphor, it's like I want to I don't have a terminal here to display it for you,
so I'll make it out to show you a demo, that or something that would look like.
Let's see. What is the date on this? October 10th, Thursday doesn't have the year.
I think this was probably seventy nine or eighty. But if you're but it's a way of drawing off, of drawing the typeface.
You describe to the computer, not the outline of the letter, but the principles by which the letter is constructed.
And so here here's how we're gonna make a capital eight.
And the first instruction in the program is take your thick pen and draw and draw a line of certain diagonal.
Then take a thinner pen, make a crossbar, then take an eraser.
And you race down off to the part that you didn't want on the top.
Going going back. You see, we had this thick line up there, but I'm going to erase part of that.
And then we go and draw with a thin pen with a similar diagonal to the bottom
and we add a serif and we add some more seraphs and then we have a better way.
Now, this is all done by a by a computer program inside of the program and has points like point five and point six.
These points are not necessarily at the edge of the letters, but in but in the spine or the letters and the.
And there's a little program that goes with it saying how to position points five and six depending on the parameters of the of the front,
depending on how how thick the thin, thick lines are, how thin the thin lines are.
And and so the same program that drew this aid would also draw many, many other A's.
If you if you said that you wanted a different style, a fine, a different different proportions, different kinds of weights.
Now that I went through and and design with this with this kind of a strange programing language,
because I'm writing a program breach, I write a program for a and a program for being a program for see it.
So on. And I got through the alphabet and had what I thought was a reasonably good alphabet.
Except that except for one letter and. S.
Turned out to be much harder than the other ones. And I couldn't.
And and for for two days and nights, I didn't have any sleep at night and I couldn't figure out how did you know?
I had twenty five letters and I. And. And. But I couldn't get the ask to look right at all.
With the system that I've been using for the other ones, I took it home to my wife.
I showed her what I. The best attempts I had.
And she says, why don't you make it. S shaped and shaped.
And I go. And so I found that in.
In 15th century how Pitino had drawn these these letters.
And other people had shown how to construct a letter s. But they don't look like a modern s particularly Louis the 14th commissioned A
for ten years that had some scientists working on how to how to do letters.
And if you if you study this and look at the geometric construction by which they did the S,
you find that they actually cheated the the lines that they draw here that don't correspond to the geometrical construction.
But they but they they fudged it at the end. Yeah.
So but finally, the third day I, I, I figured out how to write a program that would do that would do the letter s.
And it turned out to be an interesting mathematical problem. Save me.
At one point I was thinking maybe I'd have to rewrite all my books so I could avoid using the letter S.
You had to leave Stanford. But but just this slide illustrates that the that this idea of parameters,
that is all of these assets have a little different as far as the slope of the other smattered part.
That's the tricky part in the letter, was to figure out how to adjust to a slope. And so the designer can choose.
I can choose which of these slopes it will do. And then the then the the rest of the program is supposed to adapt itself to the to the specifications.
And this is the this is the principle of the design of metaphor that you that you are able to
describe with your program a large set of letters from which you can then choose later on,
the one that the one that that thinks best.
But you can you can make such such changes very easily.
The hardest part, putting the original specifications down is harder than just drawing one letter.
But once you get something like word processing and then once you've got the first draft and then you can easily make changes and.
And so it's when you try to build in of a letter that is more than instead of one letter,
you try to build a describe a family of letters as if you were being asked to draw
many different alphabets in different occasions instead of one specific alphabet.
That's why we call it metaphor. Now, this slide, I, I, I showed you because it was it it well, it was something that made me happy at the time.
This this slide was was produced by a Alfa type series types that are directly onto the film.
This particular slide is is the same as the film that I that I had in the machine was the first time
I was able to hook up my metaphor system up to a commercial typesetter and get and get real type.
Before that, we'd been using very low resolution Xerox type of machines and here we were able to go directly on the film.
And this was the this is a it's kind of a funny looking typeface to me now.
But at the time I was here, it was first time I had ever seen anything with with really high resolution coming out of the out of the system.
And so I was I was glad to be able to make this slide in 79.
Now, this this is an example of the changing of parameters, as I said.
Each letter is drawn by a computer program, which your program doesn't just doesn't draw.
Just one letter. It'll draw. It'll grow infinitely many letters depending on the specification.
So in this case, I made an example where I started with by setting the parameters for for a rather old fashioned typeface.
And I end and I have another setting of parameters that that sort of hyper modern.
And in the in-between we keep changing.
So there are six hundred and seventy letters or something on this page.
Each one is in a different typeface, but each one is getting one six hundred seventy of the way from the from the beginning to the, to the end.
And so, so generated each letter this way.
But that's in order to illustrate the idea of, of parameters.
And I wrote a paper about this where the first the first half of the paper was.
This typeface in the last half of the paper was written in this typeface, and this example appears in the middle of paper.
Some people have said that I should have chosen a translation of this psalm that also got more modern in its language as as the as I
did some other experiments where that really ought to be ought to be pursued further because we didn't have time to to carry it out.
But I added randomness into the design. See, I have this I have a program that will say how to draw a letter M.
And part of the program says, here's where to put two point one.
Here's where to put point two. If you add to this program saying but actually add a little random noise,
go a little bit away from that from the point that the that the mathematics would predict.
Then it turned out that the the typeface got it got a bit livelier and more interesting.
And musicians have noticed this when they when they have computer generated music.
If you if you if you do use it, they go speak.
One, two, three, four, one, two, three, four.
It's not that it's not interesting to listen to it all, but if it's just a little bit anticipating or behind the beat,
then you get excitement in the music and you get life. And I really have the feeling that the reason that we get a lot of the old books
that we see seems so beautiful to us is because the technology was not that good.
And there were there were these minor, minor changes that had that that that made the thing look more exciting to our to our visual systems.
The way the way we actually perceive perceive beauty is that if if something is too perfect, it's not it's it's kind of it's kind of boring.
So here I anyway started out and this was one of my first songs, but I got this one has zero standard deviation.
And this has one unit of standard deviation. This has two units and three and four and five.
And pretty soon it gets ridiculous when I, I don't know whether I carry this off any further.
Do I have another? No, I don't.
So when I when I got the standard deviation of much passed this people said it looked like people writing checks in the Berkeley co-op at midnight.
I see what I thought. But but when you have about two units.
Then it turned out that the that the effect was was extremely, extremely warm.
That you could.
That you felt that the that this was not a typeface designed by a mathematician or restricts things until I really think that there is there's some.
A lot of room for for experiments along these lines trying to put a little bit of of
imperfection into into modern technology in order to make our products look better.
Now, the system was also used successfully by by people came from the Shanghai Printing Company to Stanford.
And and we had some serious doesn't show me.
This doesn't show the same character, but we have.
But but some of the experiments were able to write programs for Chinese characters so that the same program
that would do one style of the some style and bold style would just fly just by changing the specifications.
But otherwise, the approach you have to change 19 subroutines that got the basic stroke,
but you substitute another 19 subroutines and you and you change from one style to the other.
But you put the. But you still can write thousands of programs for the individual Chinese characters that that retain.
We don't have to be changed. And so then you can imagine any any, you know, many, many different styles of type available then from.
From one design we have. This is the way the Chinese characters are constructed internally.
Instead of drawing the blackly, we just put out that part that filled in here.
So you can see how these characters are built up.
See, this one is much harder to read. This was we had a visitor from India who made Francene for Sanskrit.
There's an algorithm to watch this one. OK. This is a example of his of his program for one of the one of the letters in an Indian script.
OK, now let's see. What have I got? This is this is a Tamil Bon-Ton by another man who.
Came to visit us for a few weeks in the summertime,
and and he he was able to go back home with this and I believe he started a company now so that he can do type setting in in India in these things.
So I mentioned a lot of these things are available in the Stanford archives to
be the working documents that these people have for anyone want to pursue it.
And among the things that I that that that I think are most interesting in there are they are the proof
that we're made as soon as we're working through trying to make new typefaces with these with the system.
So there are many packages of where each page has another, has another attempt at getting at letters of the alphabet.
And so over a period of over a period of years, we kept making experiments.
These are eight and a half by 11 sheets.
And we kind of think that we would get them and we could put it on the wall and we could try to do various experiments at different different scale.
I was quite fortunate that I had the advice of of many of the best type designers in the world on this project.
Since since I'm just a amateur scientists and so on.
And they could see that this was something that they their expertize could be used to teach a computer how to do do something.
So I got for example, I got Herman OP's comments on on the design.
And these are some of these these are some of the things like, you know, a few dark hairs.
Compare this part with Monotype. You know, I had it all wrong.
And so here are some more of the OP's comments on me.
I guess that was a detail of the previous one. Here's where Herman came out to work with me.
And the first letter was that was the Laura Casey. And so the red markings on here are his drawings as to where the line should go.
And then we have before and after pictures in the archives, were we able to change the program.
This. This is I'm sorry it's so dark.
Matthew Carter took a look at the letter A and made important, you know, and really said, I've got to do that quite differently than I did before.
We can't see that too well, unfortunately. So I have comments from also from Chuck Bigelow and Chris Holmes.
Whoo hoo! We took a look at my my letter A and they gave their recipe for it.
And and there there are hundreds of these sheets showing the criticism of the early attempts that I had with the fonts and and suggestions.
And it's and it's quite interesting that to see that in most cases, the these independent critics had exactly the same suggestions to make.
But in some cases, they were completely the opposite. One would say, go this way.
The other was say go out and see the as I mentioned, I gave this talk first to the associate, to the Stanford libraries.
And in 1981 was the first time we were able to do something that I could show a slide from the archives that led to them.
I had typeset and I was able to typeset this. This program announcement for one of their one of their programs.
This was an example of when I was getting being able to set something that looked
enough like type that I could show it to a library group at Christmas time.
We gave out this recipe, whether it's 1984, we gave out this recipe for one of their Christmas parties for Stalin.
And so, again, during the years, we were eventually able to to to make something that looked respectable.
This is dated nineteen eighty five.
This typeface was it was designed by my daughter for her high school graduation using the using the program that I had.
I'll see. All she had to do was find a combination of the parameters that that would make the note the right side.
So she so she decided she would like to have letters that approximate this proportion.
And she and she worked it out so that it would come out the same width as the letters for Stanford Memorial Church and so on.
So by taking the by taking a mirror found a font that is designed to to adapt itself to the light by by choosing.
The numbers are this was she also had another one for the commencement program, which was the word commencement came out to be just the right way.
Or that, by the way, that was the first appearance of the final, the face that we call a computer model.
This was the first appearance of a computer modern. In its final version was was when she graduated from high school, I guess, fly in protest.
This is an example of one of the first experiments I made with Herman Dot.
It was it was it was good luck. This the number six is the most difficult numeral to do.
And the first thing he wanted to see when I was showing a megaphone was to do a six.
And so he dashed off a six on a piece of paper and and I keyboard.
And the the codes in that would that would draw that thing in.
And it came out an end. And by great, good fortune, he said, oh, that's a wonderful six.
I've never been able to do such a good six. And so and so we we hit it off rather well then.
Then I met American society, commissioned the typeface from the thumbs up called Oilor E.M.S. Euler's, named after a famous mathematician.
And one of the things we we were doing then was trying to use the to to use these
designs that he made and and study the process of of adapting metaphor to this metaphor
and is more intended for design or working directly with metaphor and instead of
instead of with the older style of drawing outlines and then matching outlines.
But it does it does handle the the outlines as well.
So these are examples from the from the Oilor book.
Now that the just last week I finished writing a math book where we've where we've used all our typeface for the first time.
And the book has a lot of different kinds of mathematics in it. So. So it'll be a it'll be a good test.
This is a page from the from that book. Book from one of the first trial proofs of that book where we're using Herman Parlophone for these numerals,
for example, in the letter and the letter K.
Your thought these would be examples of his of his characters.
And then I have a version of the computer modern for the for the text that goes with these these system techies is in the public domain.
As I mentioned,
and it's and this has meant that hundreds people came up and volunteered their services to to help get them to help get the bugs out of it.
And now it's spread around the world. And I have no idea how many users there are, but it's it must be in hundreds of thousands.
The it's it's now running on essentially every computer that except the very smallest computers,
more than 100 different computers that are running peak.
And it's designed to be extremely machine independent so that they will get identical results no matter which computer they use.
And it's used in many parts of the world. And here is one of the principles of this design, was that it should be able to handle foreign languages.
It shouldn't be only English chauvinistic.
And one of the surprises to us was that the hyphenation algorithm that we developed for fair use in England actually worked even better for French.
And this Professor Dominion believes that, in fact, the using text hyphenation algorithm,
he's able to do 100 percent correct hyphenation, not only in French.
He not only never inserts a bad hyphen, he never misses a place to hide, to insert a valid hyphen if there is one.
So that and not only that,
but he needed only about one fourth of the space that we needed for English to get eighty percent to eighty nine percent hyphenation,
something like that. He's able to get 100 percent with it in French.
Here's an here's a brochure from Sturt's University Press in Germany that that that one of the one
of the largest suppliers of mathematical type setting here is an example of the second European.
Conference on tech that was that was held there's a lot of our people are doing research on
different ways of making pre processes so that they can use they can use tech as a vehicle.
I guess I should mention why I'm calling a tech sort of text. We think of this as Greek letters.
Epsilon and time, because this is the Greek word.
That means both art and technology that led that led to the two things that we
were trying to blend the esthetics with the idea of doing good technical work.
Here's something that I got recently from Mexico City where someone had done a calendar with and they this they made up their own typeface for this.
They didn't do the as the main characters in metaphor.
So I don't think here's a.
And then I had a letter from Japan. They did their letterhead with another font.
And there's some beautiful work coming out of Japan with it, with Japanese version, with Jay Tech.
And here's an example of something that very simply, I can't read it, but looks it looks pretty good.
Stride typesetting is concerned and he's using megaphone in order to in order to design Japanese characters.
This is I think it was something like this with two or three years ago.
And it was the it was what they called this the third Japanese tech user group meeting or something like that.
One of the one of the most interesting things that visually is still hasn't been published and we plan to publish it later this year.
It's some work that I invited a designer to do our project,
and she did some experiments that were a lot of fun with with metaphor where she would cheat.
You had very two aspects of a design. For example, on a page.
So here you can see the different ovals are made with a different contrast
between thick and thin and the amount of pain and amounts of finning going on.
She experiments with different ways of drawing out, of making the serif set and the technical word for this at the base of basic strokes.
So her idea is to to treat to treat a system like Megafaun as a new medium for artists where they want.
And they'll learn how to control that medium as they learn how to control brush or or a chisel or other other ways of drawing letters, pens.
And so one way to do it is to is to just play with design and get a feeling for what what comes out when you give the computer its head
instead of instead of starting out with something that where you where you draw it out the way where you're in in 100 percent control.
And then you say now computer copy this. Instead, you consider the computer as part of this.
That's part of the team with you.
And and you you learn how how to have the computer have its head a little bit as it's as as you're doing the drawing.
But you learn how to to be implicitly in control instead of explicitly in control.
In Sochi, experiments with different ways of doing the finishing strokes on characters in the arms of variety of different.
Each of these is different. And is a little bit different.
It's just different ideas as to how deeply it's going to be cut at this point and and other details about the art.
So then she then she has used this to design a typeface which was going to be released later on called let's see, it's called Pandora.
And this was a preliminary example where she sent a nice a nice little booklet out by an example of of her first her first example of Pandora.
A nicely, nicely presented with and by and this hand bound with nice threads on top.
I decided that that if this project was going to be a success.
It had to be well documented and I should be able to explain to other people what we learned in this in this work.
So I was going to write a book that would explain it all. Well, it turned out that finally five books was it was the book was finally has it.
So we have now five volumes, ABC, DNG, which is which is really a complete description of what we did in our in our project.
Mark asked me for my talk. Do I have. Do I have the short 10 page version that describes essentially what I'm saying today?
In a few words. And the answer, I guess is no, I, I didn't have time to write a short book.
I only can do this five on the this. But these are.
But these books tell tell really what what we learned about, about the next year.
Computers and typesetting in, in our work. And they, you don't have to read them all but then they make nice coffee table books and so on.
And there's also interesting quotations about printing in there that you can bet you can enjoy.
But there's one by amending our donelli, in fact, from 1890.
In the first in either now the first volume is about book.
What happened? I lost the. So I just went dead.
I can't go back either. All right, well, I want to explain what's what's in those books.
The. But it's easier to explain if I have visual.
So are there any questions that I can answer? Meanwhile.
Yes, the.
They aren't being used for the very, very much right now for the designer type.
It's that that I think it's coming after me after we published this book.
The the the people who are using it to design things.
Now, are there more designing logos and ornaments right now than fan type?
I think that's in fact, I would say the the two systems,
tech and metaphor in tech is something where we're where we know it's it's it's a successful way.
The way to go about doing typesetting metaphor is completely off the wall.
Experimental might turn out. That was that it was right. It might turn out that it was wrong in retrospect.
And it was just my my best attempt to figure out the way the way computers really ought to be applied to this to this test.
But it was quite radical compared to other other other things.
And so only time will tell on that.
And people and when someone gets to be about, you know, about my age, they they often make a great mistake in their life.
And so this might be mine, you know, but I didn't care.
I just wanted to follow my my instinct. And so if it turned out to be wrong, but I think it's I think it's the right way to do it.
But it's it takes right now, it takes sort of two mentalities.
You have to you have to be have to not only have the visual expertize of a designer,
but you also have to have the little bit outlook of a computer program where you can think about what Mitta design means,
what it means to be designing a family of things instead of a single thing and that.
And so it's like the most successful things come from this, where you have two people working together.
And while many of the designers did both of these very well.
And so that's what it that encourages me. And I also see the the good efforts that come out of it.
They said India and Japan and and some people in Netherlands and so on are are doing this.
But I can't really say that the that Matthew Carter has decided to change his way of doing things.
For example, Herman Herman likes this, but he's. I don't think he's going to get a P.C. just for that.
So now the first volume it talks about is the speed of the user manual, Protech itself and Techa.
I told you about the way it does paragraphs, but it also I think the main thing that it was designed for was to handle mathematics properly.
And. And so I, I, I tried to boil down what what the best typesetters of mathematics were putting in their systems, and we lost it again.
And so so I don't know the mathematics.
Of course, this is one of the more difficult things to do to do printing on.
And so we have this little detail of the preceding, but there's not much of that.
Then there you out. The one of the nice things about Vimy is that I have illustrations by I I met a wonderful cartoonist and we worked together.
And he's got really delightful things for every chapter. So there's 36 illustrations by doing Gooby in each of these books.
The second volume is is quite different.
This is for the people who were interested in the implementation. And so this is something that turned out to be for computer science.
Well, sort of. To me,
it gave it the greatest satisfaction of all this project because I started out working on something that was
was to really be a application of computer science to to an important to an important part of the world.
But what was it? When it came back, it came right back to computer science and really and really led to a better way of writing computer programs.
And as I started working with this and finding that I have typographic tools for for documenting programs,
I was now able to write write computer programs in a better way.
And so as it is and I started it's, I guess, this buzzword now, literate programing, where I'm pushing the idea that people,
as they write computer programs, are also composing essays and they're writing for.
For human beings to read instead of four for phony computers to read.
And so this has these type of graphic tools have made it possible to to change the
way computer programs are written in a way that that they become more reliable,
easier to maintain, more portable. All these things that that are really at the heart of the software crisis are are
facilitated by having having a program that is better documented in the end,
not having a system like text that can do the type the technical typesetting
combined with another system that was that was easy to write in only two months.
I would say that that has led to a way as a method of programing as call literate programing.
And it's a it's enjoying a wave of popularity now.
The first example of of literate programing. Yes.
I mean, the main example of it is is in in volumes being v of this series, which describe the program for tech and for metaphor.
So this this computer program is certainly not the world's largest program, but it's but for a program of its size,
it's I can imagine it's easy to say that there are more people understand than any other
program of its size that it's running on more different computers than in any other program.
I would size and it's probably more bug free than any other program of its size.
And so this is is, I think,
fair to say that it represents right now is the state of the art and how to describe a computer program in a way that that people can comprehend.
And and it's the model for how we could develop even better systems for the future for for making computer programs.
Well understood and reliable. So that's the that's the content of B.
And inside it looks like this. Each of the large program is broken down into small parts, individual parts.
It's like two fifty three to fifty four and so on.
And then there index indexes to make it easy to find your way around to get from part the parts of computer scientists.
This is this is interesting. Even if they aren't interested in typesetting as an example of a of how to document a a program,
that's that's not just ivory tower, typical university scale thing.
I hope this one is darker, but this shows some of volume C of of the metaphor in the manual for metaphor.
And a lot of people are is Manafort was just released a few months ago for four years, P.c implementation.
And so we're just getting the first big wave of users.
But it's this six page shows, for example, how you can take up a pen and draw until the or or make some some interesting steps in a rather easy way.
Volume D is like volume B in a sense. This is the this is a description of how metaphysic program works inside.
This is a if if I'm talking to computer scientist and I say you want to buy one book or the other and would be the more interesting of the two,
because the algorithms for medicine go into a lot of things about graphics that are
that where the algorithms are are quite exciting and varied and also includes a lot
of things for passing in as well as it develops its own subroutines for logarithms
and everything else from scratch so that it can be completely machine independent.
So this is just another example of a large a large computer program that for people who are managing computer projects and so on.
I can recommend this as a way of doing it.
The fifth volume is about the computer model and typefaces, and this this time just contains programs for 450 different letters.
And the for example,
here's the way the lowercase eight finally came out after including the the improvements of every every page of this
book spread is something something of this form where on the right hand page we have a program from in Medford.
And then on the left hand page, we have examples of some of the letters that that program will will draw and slice.
And and this this this is a program for a lower case. A rather complicated program is one of the more difficult letters.
But it drew all three of these letters, all three of these A's given different specifications.
So here to get a typewriter style, for example, you would you say that the thick and thin, very equal and you have and.
Various things. Well, but all three of these.
All three of these A's were really drawn by the same program with different specifications than you can get, you know, anything in between.
So those are the five the five volumes that came out.
The figure was two years ago. And so so my intent was in these books to explain everything about that we learned in this project.
And if I couldn't explain it in in these books, then I think I'll figure that the project wouldn't be wouldn't have contributed anything.
If it's only has to be in some put his head.
And so I was able to celebrate last fall the completion of the project by having a presentation in the Gutenberg Museum where we're sort of like this.
For me, it was it was the climax where I could where I could see, you know,
go to one of the one of the main places in the world representing printing technology and and just sort of celebrate it.
This is this is Gutenberg upside down and backward by by my students, Godkin, who who worked on part of an innocent project over the years.
So there I was, eight and so on that I could I could run the replica of Gutenberg's original press.
And. And also I hear some lectures by people in Germany about how they're using how they're making use of that.
So there's my final slide, I guess, about the Stanford archives as being a repository of all this material.
That's it. Yeah. Yes.
OK. The programing language I use is is I call it Web.
But it's really it's really like Pascal. And the source that I write in is is a combination of tech and Pascal.
And you could use this with any two any two languages, one for documentation and one and one and one computer language.
And I have and the idea is that our programmers today already know a language for documentation in a language for their programing language.
And so they just have to learn another. And another little bit of overlay is to know for this system that mixes the two that the two together.
And this system called Web. Does this thing I have from this source program, I have two I have two programs,
one called Tango and one called we've got the one called Tango takes my source and produces a syntactically correct Pascal program that I can run.
One called Weev takes it and produces syntactic correct tech program that I can run and get and get the book printed.
And so. And so I use the same. This source that I have is it has to make my comments in InTech and my and my coding in Pascal.
But it's it's a little higher level in Pascal because he says it's modular structure built in.
So I could go on and on whatever it it allows me to present my program in the order in which I
think of it and the one one to explain it instead of the way the computer wants to read it.
But I have this just this one source for the and many people are working to develop this now to programing environments
so that they can so that they debuggers will know about this this high level language that that we're using.
It turns out to be a faster way, actually, to.
I can now write a program just for my own amusement faster with good documentation than if I just scratch it off in the old way.
So so that's why I say it's changed my own way of of of programing.
So it came right back into the heart of computer science to help help computer people.
Even though I started out not expecting any any such development at all.
Actually, my my one thing I forgot to mention about tech is that I that I wanted to be extremely stable system,
something that that won't be changing from year to year.
And and and it's bug free as possible so that people can use it as a as a fixed point in
which they can build they can put front end to tech and beckons from tech so that you could.
I think I think I can be fairly definite that if someone now has a has a car that's been composed with tech and he keeps his source files,
he would be able to to use the same program 20 years from now, 50 years from now, and get the same identical output if you wanted to.
So that. So any archival project where something is going on for years and years or where you
weren't want to where you anticipate putting out a second edition or something,
thinking something in 10 years time,
you can make use of the fact that tech is is that is going to be the main engine of it is going to remain the way the way it is now.
I'm no longer funded for this project. I'm working on something else. And and, you know, any any you can always get.
You can always improve any large system and make it better.
But there comes a point where it's much better to leave it up, to leave it firm and reliable.
There will be a meeting this afternoon at 3:00 for each conference.
Many of you would have different places than that.
Now we're going to go down and see how the online auction facilities down there.
We'll be back.